let's go to our next caller from the 7
to 0 area code caller from 772 0 go
right ahead
hi David just wanted to say firstly I'm
a new subscriber of yours and I really
enjoyed content you put out so please
keep it up man thank you on to my
question now in today's world the animal
agriculture industry is the number one
cause of global climate change whether
you're considering greenhouse gas
emissions or the fresh water use and
pollution and the products of these
animals are the underlying cause of some
of the top killing chronic diseases that
affect development I just want to know
what is your stance on the animal
agriculture industry and do you think
that one day humans will have to
transition towards a more plant-based
lifestyle yeah yeah I mean yes yes yes
my view has been that factory farming is
an absolute atrocity both from an animal
rights and a climate perspective I
believe that the evidence is pretty
clear that the as far as human health
the best things you can do or number one
reduce the consumption of processed
foods number two reduce the consumption
of foods that have been treated with all
sorts of products that we know to be
harmful to human health regardless of
sort of dosage or quantity we know that
the longest life expectancies that we
see around the world tend to correlate
with communities that have diets that
are relatively low in red meat moderate
when it comes to poultry consumption
with the majority of animal protein
coming from fish and seafood and I think
that there is a very very good chance
that maybe not 25 years from now maybe
not even 50 but maybe a hundred years
from now you're going to see human diets
basically be plant-based with lab-grown
meats or at least significantly reduced
meat consumption yeah yeah it's very
interesting answer actually I was
looking into recently how they have a
lab-grown meat um my chief concern I
guess with that I mean I'm vegan myself
but I don't know how I'd feel about that
since that sort of takes out the ethical
implications of lab-grown
if it's lab-grown you're not hurting an
animal
use a lot less resources to do something
like that but I guess my only concern
would still be if the skeletal muscle
the animal itself still contained that
LDL cholesterol that causes its quemic
heart disease and things like that yeah
the thing about that is amazingly
increasingly you know so for the the
cholesterol thing for a long time it was
considered that if you eat cholesterol
you're going to have a cholesterol
problem in blood right that's how you
measure cholesterol in humans and so
yeah very long time it was you know you
got to stay away from eggs because those
egg yolks that are high in cholesterol
are actually going to increase your
cholesterol in blood and increasingly we
know that that's not true there seemed
to be genetic predispositions either to
have a cholesterol problem or not but
more and more we're learning that there
was a major there was an overblown
cholesterol in food scare and there are
other reasons why sometimes foods that
are high in cholesterol have other
things that are not good for human
health but the cholesterol scare is
widely overblown nicey all right well
thank you so much okay appreciate the
canoe I could get through to you thank
you very much appreciate hearing from
you today's program is sponsored in part
by futur which is a social forecasting
game for your phone or web browsers that
allows players to come together and
compete with each other to predict
future events butour is built on the
principles of what's called a prediction
market which is a scientifically
validated way of leveraging the wisdom
of the crowd to better estimate the
likelihood of future events and there
are a ton of different topics including
politics and here's how it works you go
on the app find a future event that you
feel confident enough about to make a
prediction and make a bet on the outcome
you think is most likely to happen using
the apps in-game fake currency your
prediction is right you're rewarded with
more points and you compete with others
who are making their own predictions to
see who's the best forecaster there's no
real money or cryptocurrency involved
and that's kind of the fun of it the
whole point is use this social network
to prove
how good you are at predicting the
future I have an account on the futur
app and I make predictions and you can
place your bets based on my predictions
as well go to futur comm to sign up and
start making forecasts it's totally free
and it's available on both Android and
iOS and on web browsers and right now on
futur you can win cash prizes for
correct predictions about the World Cup
check it out at fut you you are calm